what's up guys got a little advice for
you now that's getting a little chilly
out there if falls here winter is coming
you're gonna want to know what you can
put on your head
beanies we're going to talk about that
today
alright guys first one that we're really
digging the chunky knit cap you guys
have seen this before you probably worn
it before in the past you might have
want a little bit looser left that
reservoir tip up there not anymore
you want to put it on tight it's a trim
keep it snug keep it looking like it's
tailored like the rest of your second
one the thin roll up your patron saint
here is going to be a Marvin Gaye you've
seen this before he has the red one roll
it up a little bit
sit on your head it's gonna sit above
your ears so dudes like me you've got
the kind of like wide Dumbo Barack Obama
ears maybe not the best clothes but
pretty fly otherwise you can pull it off
the last look we got to just look
ballsiest look the manliest look check
that out nothing here to do that other
than just have some confidence wear it
like you mean it
really want it shake it around if you
want it that's the pom pom okay guys
that's your three beanie multiple choice
answer to the question of how you're
going to keep your head warm this winter
where one where two we're three just not
all at once as always if you've got
anything he wants to answer style wise
or otherwise hit us up at social GQ calm
thanks